-It is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go, everyone.
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets,
and we're all going to
vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
[ Crowd cheers ]
Good.
You can vote all of them,
you can vote for none of them,
whatever you want,
and we'll see the results live.
Hopefully you vote for
all of them.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers, too?
-Got it.
-Every vote counts.
-Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we're going to tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
[ Laughter ]
It's a shared experience.
Alright,
you guys ready for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
First tweet is...
[ Light laughter ]
-Wow!
♪♪
-That's the joke.
That's the -- No one
has phoned it in harder.
"I got a good name for
those things -- blueberries."
Wow.
-This might get negative.
-You voted --
It's gonna be negative votes?
-Yeah,
I think it'll be negative.
-I think -- Wow.
I mean,
it was a stunned silence.
-Yeah, it was a stunned silence.
-Alright, you say 50% --
less than 50%.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Wow. I kind of agree with you.
Tariq, what do you think?
-I'm going to agree
with Higgins on this one.
-You didn't vote?
You always vote yes.
-Yes, I vote yes.
-But on this one, did you?
-I kind of did, yeah.
-Alright.
He's very honest. Votes are in.
Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
-Ooh, my God!
-Oh, yeah!
-Thirty-three.
-Was it that bad?
That's not an original name --
blueberries.
This guy kind of phoned it in
a little bit.
-More like a sentence.
-This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
There's got to be a --
-This is going to be better.
-He's got a Bat phone.
He's got everything.
-You can't call him?
-No, he has to keep
looking out his window and go,
"Oh, not yet."
-Anybody? No.
-"They need me?
No, they don't need me yet."
Alright,
let's see the results here.
I feel better about this one.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh!
-Oh, wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, thank you.
-Yeah.
-Now I know that
your thumb's-up button works,
that's good to know.
I was worried for a second.
Alright, this next one says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Alright, let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Yeah, not bad.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Batman.
Batman's still in the lead.
-Yeah.
-Alright, how about this?
Next up, it says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
We tried it.
We tried as hard as we could.
Not going to work.
Not going to be a thing.
-People tried.
-People tried hard.
They tried with kale.
Kale kind of
took off for a little bit.
-Brussels sprouts took off.
-Had one or two good records.
-Yeah.
-Cauliflower, it ain't --
just not going to do it.
Let's see the results
on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, wow!
-Oh, wow!
No, thank you.
-Some people chose
not to play at all.
"I am not --
I'm not going to waste my b--
my energy to type
in that button there."
-Wow.
-Alright,
this last one here is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I feel like it's going to be --
-I like this one.
-It's the Batman.
-Yeah, Batman for the win.
-It's gotta be. Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see the results
right here.
[ Drumroll ]
Ooh, not bad.
-Oh!
The winner is Batman!
Oh, my God.
-Whoa!
-"...a light in the sky."
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "WeTweet," and enjoy.